hello everyone and welcome to today's
webinar
at the edge of genomics sequencing
single viral particles one at a time
i am jennifer woods of labyrinth and
i'll be your moderator for today's event
today's educational web seminar is
presented by labyrinth and brought to
you by
gen script to learn more visit
genscript.com
we encourage you to participate today by
submit submitting any questions you may
have during the presentation
to do so simply type them into the ask a
question box and click send
we'll answer as many questions as we
have time for at the end of the
presentation
you may also submit any technical issues
here as well if you have trouble seeing
or hearing the presentation
i'd like to now welcome our speaker dr
manuel
martinez garcia associate professor of
microbiology
at the university of alicante spain dr
martinez you may now begin your
presentation
perfect yeah okay hello everybody
so it's a pleasure to give this
presentation
i want to thank ginascript for giving me
the opportunity to
spread out what we are doing in my lab
uh
that i think i can summarize with this
title of this
presentation at the edge of genomics
sequencing single viral particles one at
a time
so my name is manuel martinez i'm the
head of the lab of single cell
and biogenomics and we are in
spain here in alicante this tiny dot
is a beautiful place to live as you see
here beautiful beaches
and i think one of the most important
point is if i'm here
presenting these results what we are
doing is because i have a nice
people working hard in the lab as you
see here so i want to thank
all of them and also you think it's
important to
at the very beginning say thanks to our
funders
from different parts of the world so
for my presentation i want to
first introduce what
i would like to present or explain
first i'm going to focus on uh trying to
explain what is single
viral genomics probably you never hear
that
probably you hear single cell genomics
maybe
is more familiar for you but probably
the concept
the approach or the methodology of
single biogenomics is quite new for you
so i think the first part of my talk try
to
explain different parts of this
methodology
and the second part of my talk is going
to be science focus so i'm going to
explain basically different examples
quite brief about what we are doing
thanks to
single virus genomics um
so i think it's important to start with
this thing so you see here one single
cell
so a years ago um
different people from different labs
started a new field
that is called single cell genomics
single cell basically try to
address different questions biological
questions
genetics phenotypic physiological
questions
from a single unit single
live unit which is the cell right um
and with that technology we basically
have unveiled really amazing things
from different fields for example in
cancer
now we know uh different important
aspects on how a different single cells
involved in a single tumor or a
for example a really nice
studies on the genetic mosaic systems in
the biology of multicellular organisms
in the brain or for example in
embryology
how the different single cells evolve
differently
so um i think it's important that
we realize that now single cell is kind
of a
standard and festival technology
but probably not 10 years ago 10 years
ago or 15 were
quite new so this
new field called single viral single
biogenomics
starts of course with a single viral
particle
so as you see here for example when you
take a saliva
sample you can find a millions of
viruses in your saliva normally
bacteriophages
a per milliliter so what about if we can
obtain the genetic information from just
a single viral particle is it possible
is it doable
is it really complicated and this is
kind of what i'm going to address in
this
part of the presentation
i think the size matters so in any
technology or any
methodology that you want you want to
apply in science
it's important that you realize the size
of the of your population the size of
your
object that you want to study in the
case of for example a small bacterium
like the one living in our mouth or in
the gut or even in
the mediterranean sea or any other
oceans
there is there is only one to two
phenograms
of dna this is very very small amount of
dna but when you look at viral particles
even that amount of dna is even even
lower
right so then it's
quite complicated at the very beginning
to try to decipher the genetic
information from just one viral particle
but it's not impossible and that's what
i'm trying to convince
you if you click for example and you
type single cell genomics there are like
two millions of
entries in you clicking google scholar a
single um biogenomics you only
gonna find for example like a few uh
200 papers and the
is growing a lot in the last four years
so it's a field that is probably
exponentially growing basically
uh if i want to or if i need to
define what is single biogenomics is
this
genetic is the sequencing of the genetic
information from just
one individual viral particle
and how do we do it how
do we do that in the lab so step by step
is it possible to retrieve just the
genome from one vital particle
and sequence that and the answer is gs
and this is basically the summary of the
methodology
so this is you can find more details in
our recent
nature microbiology reviews that you see
here
in the left part of the slide but
basically the methodology we can
summarize in this
a few steps so we have the community can
be
from different biological samples a gut
soil
blood even marine samples sediments
wherever so then what we do in the lab
is
we add a fluorochrome normally that
sustain
the dna for example can be cyber green
cyber gold so very famous and very wide
widely used in the lab and then we wait
until this fluorochrome
gets into the capsids and then these
viral particles become fluorescently
stained then normally we go to
a flow cytometry in which you can detect
the fluorescence particle and the
and then you can tell the equipment to
put just one vital particle
in a one well for example
in this multi-well place then for
example here from just
a complex community you can sort like
300
viral particles individually each one in
each one of the worlds
and then after that normally what we
have to do is
we need to crack we need to break this
a capsid and release the dna into the
world
and then after that we pass to the whole
genome amplification
it is obvious that we cannot directly
sequence just a single
molecule of dna so we need to make
copies
so far with the technology that we have
we need to make copies
and we use different methods and one
of those can be multiple displacement
amplification
and from that they amplify dna then you
can go
for pcr screening you can hybridize with
probes you can directly
sequence the dna so this is
basically the different methodology the
different
steps that we have um there are
different ways to
short viral particles flow cytometry is
one of the most
uh famous one but microfluidic
and probably nanofluidics is very
promising
and as you know we are in the area of
microfluidics and probably
in a few i'm not sure months or a year
from now could be
doable so
then i'm gonna put one example what you
see here
is a this is a bacteriophage
p1 sample is infecting escarica choline
and then what you see here is each one
of the dots
is a viral particle of this
bacteriophage p1 that we extended with
a cyber dye and then
you can visualize very well under the
fluorescence microscopy
then you can go with this sample you can
go to the flow cytometry
and then you can distinguish very well
the population
stain it with this chlorochrome what you
see here this gate
in red color level as p1
is the population that is stainless with
the fluorochrome in the y-axis of this
plot
is fluorescence signion so in this case
green fluorescence signal
and in the x-axis is the size of the
particle
so of course when you detect or try to
detect viral particle
uh stainless with a chlorochrome they
are going to be in this
lower bottom part of the plot okay
because they are
small and then after that what we did in
our lab was
we decided to sort like several
hundred thousand of these viral
particles
and then we inspected under the confocal
microscopy
and as we expected we detected this
um viral particle in our sample
also we did like a test a plank we
say to the flow cytometry sort the noise
where
viral particles are not supposed to be i
remember that
they are in the gate p1 because they
show
fluorescent signal so this noise gate
probably is debris from different from
the processes from the sample
and as you see here in the confocal
image we didn't see these
small dots also we use
a super resolution fluorescent
microscopy
as you know it's a very really
interesting technique
that increase the resolution power of
your um
instrument of your equipment and then
basically we
tell to the flow cytometry just sort one
viral particles
and then we scan it with this uh
super resolution with a stead microscopy
and we confirmed
that the equipment just put one single
particle since then we are ready to move
on
and then we decided to as you see here
this is
one of the viral particles one of the
example we decided to
go ahead and take this methodology and
apply
a two different biological sample that
they will explain
later okay so then after that
you need to as i say to break
up and pop up the capsules so how do we
do it
so in this case we use normally
um basically we use
a chemicals different chemicals
uh in order to break the capsules
so in this case we are using a very
simple buffer that is
koh with bh14
that basically with this shock
we aim to break the capsids also we
combine with a
thermal soak with a liquid nitrogen just
combining these two things
we can break up and release the dna into
these egg wells so then we pass to the
whole genome amplification
in our case we have tested a different
type of methodologies i'm not going to
go into this
into more details but i'm going to be
happy to take more questions at the end
but for example i'm going to show uh the
results from multiple displacement
amplification
so in our case we do a real time
a whole genome amplification so
using this methodology as a qpcr or
real-time pcr
we can monitor in real time the number
of viral particles that
are leading for a positive a whole
genome amplification
i want to mention that there are in the
market other
type of whole genome method as you see
here
that malbec picoplex and many others
so in our case with real time
multiple displacement amplification you
can see
in real time in just two three hours
if your viral particles your genome
release
are being amplified as you see here so
each one of the curves that you see
here indeed are coming from the whole
genome amplification from these
viral particles so when you see a flat
a green line is because
this vital particle is not
is not amplifying anything
because of different reasons that we can
discuss later
i think it's important also to mention
that we need to put
negatives because as any this technique
is very sensitive to contamination what
you see in column 1
and column 24 are negatives
control and then you expect a flat
line which indicates that you that your
regions
are good and not contaminated with
external
dna so then you have this kind of
results in which you know very well uh
the position in the plate that render
whole genome amplification and then you
can go
to the next step whole sequencing or a
different according to your purposes so
here
also you can run in an electrophoresis
the
mda or multiple displacement
amplification or whole genome
amplification product as you see here a
very
thick band of a material that have been
amplified with that you have really
enough
a lot of dna for different purposes in
molecular biology
so basically from just one viral
particle
you can get its genome amplify
and ready to sequence there are
different
ways to amplify this
0.2 for example phenograms of dna that
we contain
in a variable particle up to micrograms
of dna
in one word you can sequence
this dna by using illumina pack bio or
nanopore in fact we have tested
all three technologies and each one has
its own advantages and i'm gonna discuss
and go
for more details but uh you this
mda or whole genome product is
compatible with
all three and probably four platforms
that we have including
a more torrent amplification sequencing
sorry
also you can we test the different
assemblers
and then you can reconstruct of course
and rebuild and and assembly the genome
of the original
viral particle and then of course there
are pros and cons
i mean there is no perfect technology
and i think it's important at this point
that
we dedicate like a couple of minutes to
explain
the benefits the pros and cons of this
technology
i'm gonna start first with the cons
so so far in our lab we have tried a
whole genome amplification for dna
viruses we have tried hard for
a rna but i have to say an admit that we
have
not a methodology
an enzyme to amplify a just a single
rna a viral a copy
so i think um it's important to mention
that because for those that are working
on
rna viruses and maybe if they want to
apply this technology
we need to go and try to find new
enzymes to amplify just
one single genome copy from a rna vital
particle so
we do not have the sensitivity uh
yet um also i think it's important to
mention that
when you work with single viral genomics
basically you destroy of course your
original viral particles so no longer
can be used for
any other phenotypical or
proteomic or whatever other idea you
have in mind so
this viral particle is no longer
existing you of course have the genome
but not the rest of the components
i think it's important because it
depends of your question
scientific question which is what it
really matters in science
think it's important to to to mention
that but
also i have to say that with synthetic
biology you might
overcome that in fact we are doing we
are now conducting a research in the lab
um doing uh thanks to jen script
to synthesize in vitro
uh the viral genome from one of the
viral particles that we'll recover
in our research and then we can clone
this
a genome in for example a rescue system
and try to produce new viral particles
so
again synthetic biology also can
help you on these questions what about
the pros
and the benefits well i think one of the
important points is
for example in microbiology we know now
for a while that most of the vital
most of the viruses living in nature
cannot be grown
in the lab so there is there are several
papers
and is very well known in microbiology
that most of the bacteria and microbes
cannot be isolated in pure culture in
our lives in apathy
so then of course the virus is infecting
these
microbes if you cannot grow the host
then it's going to be impossible to
isolate the viral
particle infecting this host so
a way to overcome this is using single
biogenomics because you directly take
the biological sample you extend
the virus and then you can go and
obtain the genome from these viruses
regardless you can culture or not or you
know the host
or not i think this is important i think
also um in the second point
probably i already explaining but you
don't need to have the host
so in fact you can identify and sequence
the genome
without having the host of the viruses
this is really great because it's
opening new avenues in
biology any dna viruses can be virtually
targeted by this technology
regardless the size can be big or small
so it can be targeted by single virus
genomics
also the third or fourth point here
is we can target regardless the
diversity present in the sample
any kind of viruses and i'm going to
explain this point
more in detail later so believe me i'm
going to hold on this question about
microdiversity
and another important point is we think
that method genomics can
recover the whole diversity genome
diversity in a sample
now we know as we demonstrated with
signal virus that this
this technology is not perfect and
single biogenomics can complement very
well
other molecular biology techniques
so and then i think is a the time to
explain with a couple of examples
uh the usefulness of this technology
so so far we have used this technology
to different samples i'm going to focus
in just
a human microbiome example well in our
case
human biome example and also
a biology example contextualized in
in our oceans i'm going to start first
from this
mediterranean survey that we conducted
in our lab
that is titled in covering high then
marine viruses
uh in which we discover which is
probably
the most abundant marine virus in
earth and i'm gonna repeat what i'm
saying so until
probably three years ago we didn't know
and we were
uh probably uh over over
looking the most one of the most
abundant viruses in our planet and we
discovered
a virus with this technology we thought
by that time in 2017 that we
already have discovered the whole
diversity of viruses present in our
oceans
as we demonstrated in our paper here in
the nature communication
we were forgetting very important pieces
in
nature so and then what we did was
we took samples from different parts of
the oceans in the atlantic ocean and
in the mediterranean sea and we sorted
several thousands of single viral
particles
and we put just one single viral
particle per well
applying this technology we amplify the
genome
and then we sequence at random totally
45 44 single viral particles
so i'm not going to explain the results
on this slide but this is
a whole genome comparison of 5 000
reference and representative genomes
living in our
asses in our oceans and what we
obtained it was that the 44
single viruses the 44 viruses that we
recovered with this new technology
were new species but not only new also
new genus
and probably some of them new families
and i'm going to focus on the one that
you see
here level us 37 f6
these values that one of my phd students
wanted to call
007 like james bond i think
i should do it but anyway there is not
so sexy now the name 37f6
is the most abundant virus
in our oceans and probably one of the
most abundant virus in our planet
and we discovered that after comparing
the abundance of this virus against the
rest of the viruses
that were in the databases in the ncbis
in the gene bank
in the red color that you see here is
the abundance the relative abundance of
our viruses
in different parts of the essence of our
planet
and as you can see here in the bar chart
plot
when we um calculated the abundance for
each one of the
viruses the top one was the 37
f6 virus recovered by single biogenomics
and was present in any single
a marine sample from any single location
that we have studied so far but the most
incredible point was
never never never we realized that this
virus was present
and living and inhabiting our oceans
and the main reason was because this
viral population
is super micro diverse
and by using a standard method genomic
assembly
and a standard genomic assembler
this struggle to recompose and
reassemble
this genome and always we were missing
these important pieces in our viral
databases
so a final single biogenomics can
overcome
the problem of microdiversity the
problem of
reconstructing these super complex
puzzles
just going from one viral particle at a
time
we can overcome this type of problems of
genomic assembly
with that i think i can convince you
that single vital genomics
is a novel technology that can be
powerful
to unveil important pieces that we are
missing
in our planet
and the second example i'm going to be
brief is
we also try to implement the technology
in the human microbiome surveys
and for that case uh what we did was we
took saliva
from a healthy group and also saliva
from
people immunocompromised in this case
with
um immunodeficiency in
iga which is what the most abundant
antibody
in our mucus and i think it's
you know that is important and because
it plays a role in defense
against different pathogens so we took
the different samples and then we
process
through different like standard
methodogenomics and also
single biogenomics so in this case
we recover several
viruses we sequence several viral
particles coming from
different viral samples and as you see
here we unveiled
the genome from different bacteriophages
in this case infecting
estratococcus which is a very abundant
microbe in our mouth
and when we plot the abundance again
these viruses were ubiquitous
widely spread between different samples
and
a very abundant in saliva
so again with this
technology i think we can answer
different fundamental biological
questions
in biology i think we have with this
tool
that i'm a that we have done in this
presentation
we have covered what is single
biogenomics
from the very beginning to the very end
what is the usefulness and different
application of single biogenomics
uh with that i think again i want to
thanks especially
oscar for nas which is a one of
my favorite collaborator because he
opened
his flow cytometry facility
he's very crazy like me and very
supportive and we decided to try to
implement single biogenomics
in collaboration so also i want to thank
many other people
from different institutions in spain and
abroad bigelow
laboratory doctor jaquin martinez
and sylvia athena step castle and other
people providing samples
and my founders so
i want to thank er for being in the
other part of the lane
and i'm going to be super happy to take
your questions
and answer in the chat or maybe
later through email or whatever other
things that we have for uh exchanging
opinion
so thank you very much and with that i
think i think i'm done thank you very
much thank you very much
thank you dr martinez for your excuse me
informative presentation
we will now start the live q a portion
of the webinar
if you have a question you would like to
ask please do so now
just click on the ask a question box
located on the far left of your screen
we'll answer as many of your questions
as we have time for
let's get started our first question is
let's see rna is very fragile
in quotes is this one reason as to why
it cannot be sequenced
in this manner okay thank you very much
for
the question i think it is interesting
so
it could be a reason why
renee is very recalcitrant for
amplification
but i think the the probably
the important point is that we don't
have
an enzyme in the market with the
minimum or enough sensitivity to amplify
just a single rna molecule as we do
for dna so for example we
had a project an ongoing break in our
lab in collaboration with another lab in
the united states to
implement a single biogenomics for
rna and we have tested a bunch of
commercial enzymes
to be used in the lab and they were
unsuccessful so that's what i can
tell thank you dr martinez our next
question is
how do you pick up rare mutations in
this technique
if you are looking at one single viral
particle
i think it's it's obviously a very
interesting question
so it is true so if you only have a
single genome it's impossible to
identify
if you have a polymorphism and a smith
or
a mutation but in general i think
what i recommend is of course
to combine for example with method
genomics or
if you have other reference genomes
similar to
your virus and then you can compare your
genome against
a reference genome either in your
in-house database or in public database
also another important point is maybe
you can sort
several dozens of viruses belonging to
the same population
and then after sequencing you can
compare all of them in order to check if
you have some smiths in our case what we
did was
after sequencing a bunch of single
viruses we compare
against several method genomes coming
from the same sample
and then we could identify it as nips i
think with that
i answer more or less the questions i
think is
very interesting
all right thank you dr martinez our next
question is
let's see how can this affect or can it
be applied to the genomic sequencing of
sars kobe 2 variants
well so far we can't unfortunately as i
said in
one the first question we don't have an
enzyme
with the sensitivity to amplify just a
single
viral particles so
you have to realize that this
amplification has to be robust has to be
reproducible
and unfortunately we don't have an
enzyme with such
capabilities in the lab there are like a
few options that are not commercial but
they are on the way so
all right thanks again dr martinez we
have some more questions coming in
let's see uh what is the most common
issue seen in the technology
slash instruments used when attempting
to sort through single viral particles
so um one of the commons one of the
thing is
so i always recommend if
to do the sorting in a core facility
that has experience or a loan trajectory
working with
a small things so bacteria or
viruses because many or several
core facilities only work with
eukaryotes eukaryote is a big thing
compared to a virus
and then the scale is totally different
and normally they have the instrument
more tune or optimize to this
big size so my recommendation personal
recommendation is to try to start or
with our core facility center with a
long experience with
this if you go to one of these places
probably
the aces the typical issues that you can
have
probably is going to be i would say
very a piece of cake because if the
people the director or the technician
they have a long
experience detecting viruses and
bacteria is going to be easier
to do the sort team
okay thanks again dr martinez our next
question is
how do you make sure the flow cytometric
reagent
slash consumables or
buffer is free of virus
okay so normally the flow cytometry
regions
are externalized and
and also most of the sorters flow
cytometry sorters have
several filters in the
fluidic lane so in our case
um what we do is we prepare in-house
uh the regions but you can buy so
that this regens and seed fluid can be
uh
perfectly buy from different companies
in our case we
um heat the buffer up to 400
degrees so and then we make
this buffer and regions very estoril
right and also we filter through 0.02
but as i would say they are
sterilized so viruses should not be
present
in these buffers and regions
use it for flow cytometry sorting
thank you dr martinez our next question
is
what is the error rate in the
amplification step
is it low enough to evaluate single
mutations in the sequence dna with
certainty
the answer is yes because they for
example the polymerase that we use in
the lab and other people use for single
cell genomics is normally
v29 has a lower error rate
that most or all
tacman polymerases that are in the
market so v29 the polymerase is a very
um vital enzyme so you
can trust because if you trust in your
tachman polymerase during your pcr
then you should trust much more during
the whole genome amplification
because the chance to introduce an
artifi an artifact and
mutation that is not actually present in
nature
is is very low
thank you dr martinez our next question
is
with regard to the challenge of
analyzing rna viral genomes
would it be possible to do reverse
transcription of the rna viral genome
and then
amplify the dna genome that is generated
obviously yes and this is what we try um
so we try in the lab uh so first
albreto transcription and then an
amplification but one of the problem is
a i think here the delimiting the
bottleneck
is exactly the right transcription
so normally we do retrotranscription in
the lab in a bulk of
rna so you have millions so in a regular
extraction from just a single cell you
have
a thousand of different rna molecules
right
so in this case you should think that
you really have one
so when we try this
when we scale down until only
a few molecules we realize the
amplification that retrotranscription
was not
robust was not reproducible so then
finally our results indicate that we
don't have
an enzyme that can do as uh as good as
we do
for the uh dna but uh obviously
yeah the answer is this is the obvious
thing to to try right write a
transcription and then
the second step um whole genome
amplification of this
cdna and in fact the second step is not
to the bottom leg because we can use the
feet 29 to amplify this c dna
so the so the so the complicated thing
is to have
this first step done with just a single
molecule
you know without introducing
contamination
and also by using a robust technology
that
you can reproduce in any single lab but
so far we cannot do it
thank you again dr martinez our next
question
is is it possible to separate
bacteriophages and bacteria and then
sequence both with the single virus
bacterium sequencing of course
i think it's a good question yes you
don't need to
you can have a mix of virus and bacteria
in the same sample and then what you can
do is distinguish that
in the flow cytometry because bacteria
any single bacterial cell is going to
have
a higher size right and then with the
flow cytometry
is going to pop up in a different part
of the graphic
is separated from the viral population
so then you can tell to the flow
cytometry pick up
for example a few cells or pick up a few
viruses from the same
sample you don't need to separate and
sort it out first
by filtering or other um centrifugation
methods you
should not you cannot you don't you
don't need to separate viruses from
a bacterial fraction so you can use the
same sample
and then you can tell the flow cytometry
to short whatever you want
so in fact we sometimes do that
thank you again dr martinez our next
question is
can we amplify rna
um no as i said
from a single molecule the answer is
not unfortunately so we can
amplify rna from a few molecules a few
maybe
rna viruses but not from a single level
a viral particle a renaissance particle
okay thank you again dr martinez our
next question is
what type of specific equipment do we
need to implement single virus genomics
okay so uh we need like a
i would say a couple of instrument
couple of three instruments
one of course is a flow cytometry sorter
but i would not recommend to purchase
a one for your lab specifically you can
use
a one short term policing at your
university or research center so there
are many
universities having this core facility
flow cytometry
centers so the second instrument
that probably you need to buy for your
lab is
for doing the whole genome amplification
so but it's not very expensive we are
talking about
15 000 euros or dollars or 10 000
so it's not that expensive this
equipment is
i think is useful to amplify doing this
whole genome amplification
and maybe you need to
if you want to do this whole genome
amplification in real time
uh monitoring as i
show in the presentation uh monitoring
in real time maybe
you need to spend a little bit more but
it's not that much it's 20 000 euros or
dollars
and the other thing that is very very
cheap is
a uv strata linker so this uvs
throttling car is 5000
euros so other than that the rest of
things that you need is common for any
single lab of course a dedicated
area for free of contamination with a
flow hood specifically dedicated for
this application
but other than that this is what we need
looks like we have time for one last
question during whole genome
amplification
i think it is important to consider dna
contamination from reagents or
manipulation
how can we prevent that okay i think
this point is important because dna
contamination
can introduce a lot of biases
in your data so i think
it's important to work on this one
important point is during the sorting
what we do is we use well now with the
copy
we are used to that but we cover with a
mask with a glasses
with a lab coat
after sorting what we do is during whole
genome amplification we use a dedicated
specific flow hood only used for a whole
genome amplification
and another important point is to
decontaminate
as much as possible your regions
and for that you can do two things
either
by and purchasing one kit that
is in the market that already implement
the contamination
of dna from the regions is served by
kia gen i have to say that they don't
have any
stockholders anything from kia and
another
thing that you can do is what we do in
our lab and i know that many other
peoples working on single cell genomic
studies
they prepare their own cocktail as many
people do for example for
a regular pcr and then what we do
is when we have this buffer
this cocktail for whole genome
amplification we decontaminate it using
ultraviolet light with for a few minutes
with this uv what you do is you
cross-link the dna present in regions
a while you maintain the efficiency and
the activity of the enzyme
the v29 enzyme is pretty robust even
when you
uv for a a lot of minutes
still they work fine then sign works
fine so don't worry about that so and
with that just
doing irritation with ub you can
remove and get rid of the dna
thank you dr martinez do you have any
final comments for our audience
yeah so i think
so say thank to the audience so i
appreciate that they are in the other
part of the
lane so i think this has been funny and
i appreciate
your interest on this uh talk and and i
also want to thank jen script for
organizing all of this that i think is
amazing
and thanks to two of you
well thank you again dr martinez for
your time today and for your important
research
we would also like to thank lab roots
and our sponsor jen script for
underwriting today's educational webcast
before we go i'd like to thank the
audience for joining us today
and for their interesting questions
questions we did not have time for today
and those submitted during the on-demand
period
will be addressed by the speaker via the
contact information
you provided at the time of registration
this webcast can be viewed on demand
lab routes will alert you via email when
it's available for replay
we encourage you to share that email
with your colleagues who may have missed
today's live event
until next time goodbye